I have to turn it down for copyright
reasons good morning John
I have to make a makeup tutorial today
and I realized that I have no makeup
catherine has no makeup and no one we
know has makeup because we are in the
social group of people who do not
highly-prized the evenness of one skin
so we're gonna target I'm very
comfortable here
it's my target spend a lot of time here
though I admit that I haven't spent a
lot of time in the makeup aisle so
Catherine and I were walking up and down
the makeup aisle and I've seen all these
beautiful fancy people on the walls and
in the aisles and I was trying to think
of myself who do I really admire who
wears makeup first thing him in my mind
was Katniss Everdeen the protagonist of
The Hunger Games in the opening
ceremonies of the Hunger Games they talk
a lot about profession and she's totally
into it
so thinking about that and I came to the
book section to check this out and
actually read about what Katniss is
wearing at the opening ceremonies at the
first Hunger Games and here's what it
says my face is relatively clear of
makeup just a bit of highlighting here
and there and that's all it says about
Katniss is make up the the outfit of
course is much more sensational than
that but I think that that's the look
that I am going to go for not a lot of
makeup just a bit of highlighting here
and there I'm a little bit worried about
getting the one that features Ellen's
face because it makes me feel old that
is a lot of ingredients I don't know if
you know this but shaving hurts
sometimes it stings just worry don't
like to do it so I'm gonna start with my
foundation of course and I'm gonna be
doing much the city with my glasses on
and you will say oh my god Hank you look
so weird with your glasses off I don't
have no idea how to get this open it's
like they've stuck it inside of a single
block of hard plastic I have no idea how
to open this God what kind of woman is
strong enough to do it oh there we go I
did it and this is I think how makeup
works in my I doesn't feel good blend it
into the neck there okay that's looking
good so what I'm going for here is like
you know district 12 kind of smoky but
subtle look I'm gonna attempt that with
this silver shimmer eyeshadow which I'm
gonna put around the edges to give kind
of a sparkle and then I have this which
is dark with a with a nice white
highlight that I think will give us a
really good dramatic smoky look in fact
it says on the back of this dramatic
smoky look how do you put makeup on your
eyes if you have to see how's it your
eyes are closed but they have to be open
how do you do this
I look like I've been beaten with a hose
now I'm gonna go with white across the
brow bone here it's just so
counterintuitive
why the hell would anyone do this why
would you put a stick in your eye I
don't know if you people thought I was
gonna take this quite so seriously yeah
oh that's bad mother of poo I am the
worst at putting on oh that's not coming
off since I did a little bit of extra
fun with my eyes I'm gonna be very
simple with my lips it was the third
time I put on makeup for this video this
does smells good so I wanted a cool look
nice dark smoky district 12 look and
this is what I'm going for and if I had
ever put on makeup before in my life I
think that it would have been really
awesome this is my Katniss Everdeen look
everybody I hope that you enjoyed it and
tomorrow you can go buy Mockingjay the
next book in The Hunger Games series
which I am extremely excited about and
of course tomorrow is also John's
birthday but I'm not gonna talk about
that right now I will say that while I
was waiting for Mockingjay to come out I
read the shipbreaker by Paolo Bacigalupi
- nerdfighter symbols up for Paulo by
Seagal Lupe's the shipbreaker you should
check it out thank you ladies for
putting on makeup for special occasions
but I think that it's important to note
that we guys we think you're pretty all
the time because you're beautiful John
you will see me and a lot of
nerdfighters tomorrow
their first remit I have no idea how to
get this off of my face now that I have
it on so I think I'm just gonna get a
good ol barn edit my video like this no
one's watching